turning a profit and protecting the
environment this ice cream parlor pulls
it off the Florida ice brand sells for
one euro 20 a scoop it's tasty and it's
also ethical the most important thing is
that the manufacturing process is carbon
neutral we care about climate protection
and people who go to an ice cream parlor
can relate to that and maybe want to do
something for the environment
Olaf Hearn has been making Florida ice
in a Berlin suburb for over 30 years
his son is head of marketing and has
taken the company's marketing strategy
in a new direction my son gave me a
wake-up call he studied hydrogeology at
university I listened to what he had to
say at that point I hadn't paid any
attention to the environment at all no
it's my hobby the company's invested
over a million euros in clean technology
for things like its vehicle cooling
systems these are for these vehicles all
have a tech tech cooling so the
compressor can be taken out and when
we're out in the city we're using a
silent cooling device that's carbon
neutral we don't yet have electric
motors but we're working on it the
production process is powered by
renewable energy sources such as the
solar power units on the factory roof
demand for the panel's rose in part
thanks to companies like Florida ice
there's also a growing number of solar
parks in Germany if all the solar panels
in the country were pieced together
they'd cover an area larger than Lake
Constance
until a few years ago the panels were
manufactured in Germany but these days
production has been relocated to Asia
all that's left here in Germany are the
industry service providers such as
quality control here at the photovoltaic
Institute in Berlin environmental
engineers test the standards of solar
panels and modules using methods devised
here at the Institute methods such as
the peel test we test the workmanship of
the modules to see if the individual
layers are held together with sufficient
strength to do that we peel off layers
and measure how wide they are that
allows us to calculate how strong they
are if they're well made or if there are
production errors their skills are in
demand
the Institute earns revenues of some two
and a half million euros a year from
quality control of solar panels its
founder is reaping the benefits of his
visionary idealism the whole idea of
doing something with solar energy was
born out of environmental concerns I
took a course in solar energy in 1986
and gained a doctorate in the field in
93 I went into it as an idealist now
it's big business Florida ice is also a
bigger business than it looks these days
it supplies supermarkets and
manufactures some 10 million litres of
ice cream a year the family is proud
that its electricity needs haven't grown
even though the business now makes four
times as much ice cream as it did five
years ago
all of Hern says their investments have
paid off and regrets more companies
aren't following their lead
even though climate change is gathering
pace we need to look out for our
grandchildren
hopefully the worst-case scenario can be
averted I'm not the type to spread alarm
and despondency but I have to say it's
serious do something get active Olaf
Hearn is doing something and if all goes
to plan Florida ice production will be
completely carbon neutral within the
next three years
you